well you are here because you got some
new movies coming out we're going to
talk all about these new movies the
first one
of course is the most talked about thing
on digital right now
zack snyder's director's cut of justice
league
i mean it has blown everybody's mind and
the fact that
it even got made is what's crazy because
well first of all can you just run us
through the difference between
this new version and the 2017 original
well you know the thing about it i think
that a lot of people don't realize
is that i actually wasn't technically a
part of the original japanese league
uh i was cast in ben affleck's batman to
play the villain
and we shot a scene to tease our
match-up
in the batman film that was going to
appear at the end of the film so that
scene was then reconfigured
to tease a justice league two movie
that didn't happen uh so this
version the difference for my character
in in this version
is that zack restored the original scene
that we shot to tease the batman movie
that never happened and that's what
fans will get to see at the end of this
and then they'll get to see some extra
added
bonus uh where zack actually officially
invited me in and now i am actually
technically a part of the
the the zack snyder diverse yeah i like
this very very much because
the movie as i was kind of alluding to
before it came about
because fans online they demanded it
they wanted it
they they wanted to see something
different did you want to see something
different too was this something that
you know ever crossed your mind i mean
you
i would think so if i was in it and then
i wasn't in it well
yeah but it's unique for me i mean you
know i i had
at the time you know once batman got
canceled i kind of
wrote it off and i thought okay this is
over um i had actually shifted gears and
started
working with the studio on an origin
film for deathstroke
that also didn't happen uh so for me i
just
let it go and yeah two weeks before
justice league came out theatrically i
got a call from one of the executives
who said oh by the way we retooled the
scene and it's gonna it's back in at the
end
to advertise a justice league too much
you know you could have told me
but see that okay so that answers a
couple of the other questions that i had
because i wondered like is there a world
where deathstroke could have
a standalone or because he has been
revived now
in this one is there a series is there a
world where something like that could
happen
well unfortunately i don't own the ip
but i will say that you know a very
prolific director gareth evans who i'm a
huge fan of i worship at the altar of
gareth evans who did the raid and raid
2.
uh we had a long talk one night on skype
um
and he wanted to shoot an origin
film for deathstroke with me in in kind
of in the
in the air of the raid um that didn't
happen
uh so but let's manifest this but listen
it's been two minutes but joe there's
been too many like bike bike bike maybe
maybe no remote
for something like in the universe
it's not gone you know no no it's
definitely back and i think that that
fans appetites
are wedded for more they want more and
you know the the deathstroke origin
wouldn't necessarily have anything to do
with this path it was its own separate
story
so it isn't necessarily a part of that
universe it was its own you know
separate part
have you talked to any of the cast
members from justice league about the
new version and
you know what folks think and have you
sat down and watched the four hours
i so i have not spoken to any of the
other cast members but
uh i've talked to zach a bunch i talk to
zach all the time
uh and uh and as far as sitting down and
watching the full four hour version yeah
i did uh
two weeks ago i sat down and uh with
sophia and
we watched it all the way through i i
loved it yeah four hours straight
through
yeah but people can watch it in pieces i
think if they're intimidated by the four
hours
you know each piece is about
30-something minutes and there's six of
them and then an epilogue so you can
kind of watch a piece and go do your
thing come back
so you can kind of do it series way like
you do 30 minutes 30 minutes like you're
watching a series yeah you could be
sit down and watch the whole thing at
the same time you re-shot
these scenes with zach during the
pandemic yep character had a mohawk
was that your idea yes it was i loved
yeah i loved it
so tell me about that like you know you
went from
going coming back in the pandemic
shooting these revive scenes and now
you know there is a big chunk of you i
would like 20 25 minute big chunk of you
yeah you know um yes like i said i i had
let go
um after you know my character was also
going to be the main villain in
a couple of different incarnations of
the suicide squad part two
which didn't happen uh so
listen there's a trend here this
interview is not gonna be
didn't happen but this is this interview
is happening so here we are yeah yeah
so um so you know i had let go of it
and then of course zach and i were
working on a different project uh
there's this great
3d animated series that's a prequel to
zack's army of the dead uh movie that
comes out
and uh that i star in that'll come out
later the in the year and zach and i
were working on that and he said hey i
have this other thing that might be
going on
would you want to play deathstroke again
so it was this call kind of out of
nowhere four and a half years later
uh asking me if i wanted to put the suit
back on and i said yes
but i've had a lot of time to think
about the character and there's a few
things that i'd like to do
namely the mohawk i love that so and he
was open then to your suggestion that
collaboration
yeah and and i think you know as an
actor you want to put your stink on
things
you know when you when you look at like
you know what tom hardy got to do with
bane the character of bain that was a
very unique take on that or even heath
ledger's
joker was very unique to him and you
know i had ideas and things that i
wanted to do with deathstroke and
although i would appear briefly
in this new version i wanted to start
placing those things
in case but that's how a lot of whether
it's like you know
dc or mcu that's how a lot of them start
you see a little snippet of somebody
in a in an early you know movie then you
might get a little bit more and then all
of a sudden you get their story
well that's how it was supposed to be
with batman yeah you know that's we were
teasing him and then
and then we were going to shoot them
okay i'm not giving up on that let's go
from the blonde mohawk to a dark
ponytail
for this new movie shoplifters of the
world it is in theaters and on digital
on friday you play a radio dj
um who is taken hostage and you're
forced to play the smith's songs
over and over again all night tell me
about first of all tell me that ponytail
was a clip in or did you grow it
well no my hair was down to here when we
shot so that's
this is all this is all mine and uh and
this is all mine
um tell me about this movie and because
you know
i know it's a passion project for you
yeah it was a passion project
uh you know it independent film the
fashion in this film is crazy it's a lot
of fun do you remember something that
you wore back in the 80s that
you're like nah don't ever want to see
it again oh boy
uh jeez i mean i was really young
in the 80s so i didn't have a lot of
choice it was more like i think it was
like l.l bean
flannel shirts which i would totally
wear today no problem and
the crazy thing is like you know air
jordans
have never gone out of style and are
even more popular now so i've actually
gone back and
re-bought all of those air jordans that
i wore playing basketball as a kid so
you got like that original red black
i got a ball i got the breads i got the
bands i got the royals i got the shadows
i got it all
i love it i love it
you know it is all about the music of
the smiths in this uh
film what what kind of music and what
were you
super passionate about as a teenager
because this guy that you know in the
movie he's super passionate about that
i was really passionate about music back
then yeah i really was i mean sports i
was i played a lot of sports then
uh but i was i was really passionate
about music
um and and much like my character in the
film i i was
i was a metal head a lot of the records
that i had even as a little kid i had
like
you know old van halen david lee roth
records that i would play
over and over and then i had like when
appetite for destruction came out that
that changed everything yeah so what do
i do
i dedicated to anywhere you know we see
you getting
asked for advice by one of the young
cast mates at one point
um and you say you would dedicate a song
to her so what's an actual good piece of
advice for anybody who's looking
like to make a move and to sweep
somebody off their feet what's the best
piece of here's how you get her well
i think there are certain things that
shouldn't change
ever that's me personally and people can
argue with me all they want
but you know i'm a big believer in you
know there's this trend of like let's
meet up
and it's like no go pick her up thank
you go make a plan thank you
go plan the evening thank you plan the
place to go to dinner
then the place after if it goes well
maybe the little piano bar
afterwards like take her on a little
adventure invite her into your world all
she has to do is show up
look great you know i'll pick you up at
eight be ready and then we'll go and
that's it take care of everything
and i think too many guys of this
generation
w-y-d on the test no names no sir
texting go pick her up and go talk to
her face-to-face
put the phone down that makes my heart
smile have you ever called into a radio
station and dedicated a song
we grew up in the like i would call
delilah or whatever
that was a thing that was a big thing or
like at the time there were like hot
songs like i remember getting out of
out of school and if i didn't have
practice then it was like you wanted to
run home
to catch that video because you knew it
was going to be number one on mtv and
you had to get home to see that thing
at 3 25. thriller was that for me
like your new thriller was going to play
it was like crazy because it was like a
mini movie and
you would always try to time it okay top
of the hour you know we got to get there
you have the vcr tape in there and you
know hit the record button exactly
exactly what's on your playlist now like
what's what are you loving
oh man i am i am down a tool rabbit hole
right now
so i am like i am watching danny carey
who is the drummer for tool
i'm obsessed with danny carey and uh and
so i
i watch danny carey drumming videos like
all day long like while i'm brushing my
teeth i have them on on my phone and
while i'm walking around
i don't know what it is is there
anything that gets you guys up partying
maybe in the kitchen if you're cooking
like the the song that makes y'all move
uh we have very different musical tastes
i will say that no there is common
ground
like like she loves the smiths like
she's really you know she's into the
smith so that was great but uh but you
know we
we kind of grew up listening to
different things so
when i go down i built a i have a home
gym in the basement so i go down there
and i'll come back up and she's like
what was that devil music
you were playing and that's
generally how my music is viewed but no
but i but you know i can
we have common ground there's like i'm
digging into like electronic and dj you
know and i used to have techniques in a
rain mixer so i have like you know wait
don't tell me you are the ones and twos
don't let me find out you dj is set or
two i have on my vinyl
at the house come on joe mangano we're
learning things about you thank you so
much for stopping by